okay
wisst ihr was das ist
pass auf
pass auf das ist das fragen-lotto ihr
könnt nur Erfahrung darf darin gewinnen
was für schlimme Fragen man euch alle
stellen kann und was wir haben lose
Fragen die roten sind die schlimmen
Fragen die Grünen sind die harmlos wir
können so viel ziehen ja ihr könnt alle
ziehen ihr könnt ihr könnt machen was
ihr wollt
aber wir haben uns echt überlegt wie bei
euch ärgern können nee
ja habe ich selbst gemacht DJ Ötzi ist
beim letzten Mal richtig sauer geworden
nein
also bitte was wie lautet die Frage
wer ist für eure erste Single
verantwortlich
da schwingt mit auch die erste Single
ist eigentlich nicht so dolle
nein ja natürlich ist unsere
Plattenfirma dafür verantwortlich
klar gibt es bestimmt andere bessere
Songs auf dem Album aber wir machen das
Beste draus und wir finden wir finden es
toll also wir mögen unsere Single sehr
schön die Diplomatin hat gesprochen
werdet ihr überhaupt noch ein zweites
Album herausbringen
klare Antwort klar
ja mit Sicherheit weil wir sie jetzt
schon Pläne haben wir unser nächstes
Album
und von daher wir wissen dass wir es
schaffen werden wir sind überzeugt davon
dass wir auf jeden Fall im Musik
Business festen Fuß fassen können und
von daher blöde Frage
ist für euch wir machen es okay cool
so meine Frage ist seid ihr überhaupt
selbst mit der Zusammenstellung von Navi
zufrieden
gut das hatten wir jetzt schon im
Interview aber ich will trotzdem wissen
ihr seid überhaupt nicht zufrieden du
wolltest doch auch Samstag Sonntag
natürlich
ähm hätte man sich eine andere
Konstellation gewünscht hätte man sich
wahrscheinlich ausgesucht aber ganz
ehrlich ich bin zufrieden ihr auch klar
hallo jo jo
die Frage ist ein bisschen verwirrend
weil hier wird gefragt wie geht ihr mit
euren zahlreichen Konflikten um ja die
habt ihr ja sicher weil ja so
unterschiedlich seid
in der Popstars Staffel ab und an mal
einen Konflikt aber zwischen uns
eigentlich nicht also
wir haben keine Konflikte wir haben
zwischen keiner von euch jemals also man
sollte niemals nie sagen aber
ja man also klar geht es mal so wenn
einer vielleicht mal morgens mit dem
falschen Fuß aufgestanden ist oder so
dass man einfach mal ein bisschen Ruhe
braucht am Tag oder so aber es ist nicht
das wird das Konflikte nennen können
okay also es gibt mal ganz minimale
Meinungsverschiedenheiten aber der Arlo
complex okay
hier hat jemand keine Frage so und jetzt
kommen die Grünen
wie teuer Album in der kurzen Zeit so
super werden ja dazu sage ich nur wir
sind la V und wir haben alles drauf und
nein
ja wir haben einfach Spaß an dem was wir
machen und wir arbeiten haben und
deswegen ist es so toll geworden super
die nächste goldene warum habt ihr es so
weit gebracht
wie geil sind nein papa was ist das was
muss man haben um bei der Castingshow
bis zum Schluss durchzukommen auf jeden
Fall muss jede einzelne die bei der
Castingshow jetzt so wie wir
durchgekommen ist eine eigene
Persönlichkeit haben und einfach diesen
Willen Musik machen zu wollen und ja
das haben wir geschafft und wir können
es jedes Mal wieder beweisen wenn wir
auf der Bühne stehen gut
meine Frage was macht euch so stark
ziemlich einfache Antwort erstmal unsere
Fans
nein erst mal unsere Fans weil ihr seid
nämlich dafür verantwortlich dass es uns
gibt und das ist richtig geil also wir
haben eure Stärke im Rücken und genauso
gut stärken wir uns gegenseitig unsere
Familien unsere Freunde und genau das
macht uns so stark und weil es Leute
gibt die an uns glauben und alles andere
interessiert uns nicht
auf meinem Zettel steht was habt ihr was
andere nicht haben
und ähm
möchte sie mit mir zusammen beantworten
also ich finde wir haben den Vorteil
dass wir einfach mal alle komplett
verschieden sind wir haben verschiedene
Charaktere
wir haben nicht 90 60 90 sondern 120
90 und
noch mehr
wir sind einfach mal was ganz frisches
und ich glaube das braucht Deutschland
mal und nicht jede Band ist bringt
unbedingt immer so ein Witz aber
trotzdem so eine Professionalität mit
und ja das ist einfach mal frisch und es
braucht Ihr Tisch und ihr könnt euch
bestimmt mehr mit uns identifizieren als
90 60 90 und ungefähr 30 mal mit dem
Computer bearbeitet 30 30
also wie gesagt müsste Bescheid
super
ich danke euch vielmals es war super
sensationell